c'est ça les questions les plus
sérieuses à poser en France à ce moment
alors
[Musique]
vous voulez pas répondre madame une
question pour la télévision française
et vous madame vous n'êtes pas je
voulais simplement vous demander
justement c'est ce qu'il faut leur dire
Madame il faut le leur dire ça
non je voulais simplement vous demander
madame est-ce que vous pensez des barbus
[Musique]
est-ce que c'est
ça n'existe pas pour nous
[Musique]
non
c'est un je n'aime pas la tenue des
hommes actuels des jeunes gens surtout
non parce que les jeunes gens portent le
porte là-bas ont tendance à porter la
barbe actuellement bon la barbe et puis
les cheveux longs tout ça de lamentable
mais il y a quelques années les hommes
portaient la barbe il y avait différents
non
marie avec une moustache et l'enlever en
14 madame aimez-vous les barbus
ils ont plus chaud l'hiver
[Musique]
dites moi Mike aimez-vous les barbus je
me les aime mais je me méfie pourquoi je
me méfie parce que souvent là-bas
dissimule un fuyant alors je fais
attention je regarde dessous
[Musique]
marier qui la coupe je crois que je lui
demanderai aussi ah oui oh oui à
certains barbu que j'aime bien sûr si
vous ne parlez Barbe-Bleue là moi par
exemple parce que il a fait souffrir un
tas de femmes alors vous savez je reste
quand même femme avant tout mais enfin
j'aime bien par exemple Charlemagne
Charlemagne à la barbe fleurie c'est
tellement jolie et puis un j'aime aussi
le genre petite barbiche vous savez
comme tous les jazzmen non non c'est pas
mal et puis je dois dire que un Pisani
tu as un autre ministre de l'Agriculture
il n'est pas tellement mal avec sa
petite barbiche ensuite moi je travaille
avec deux barbus tous les soirs au
théâtre de l'Alhambra dans l'opérette
que joue avec Bourvil et je dois dire
que je n'ai pas me plaindre de ces deux
barbus c'est Marco Perrin qui joue le
rôle d'un dur mais dans le fond de teint
tendre et Max Dero qui est un tout
farfelu qui est un garçon charmant
on pensait pas que c'était une question
de timidité
non parce que je crois que ce serait le
contraire pour être timide et effacé
il ne faut pas avoir là-bas justement
soyons comme tout le monde passons
essayons d'être discret hors une barbe
ça se remarque mais peut-être pour se
virer ah ça peut être il va falloir que
je dois dire je demande à Marco ce soir
des barbus les hommes qui portent les
bars
Sylvia rouge c'est affreux et s'ils ne
sont pas rouge si c'est bien soigné ça
va être beau ça dépend c'est ça les
questions les plus sérieuses à poser en
France à ce moment
alors que pensez-vous des hommes qui
portent la barbe j'aime pas ça
[Musique]